we're gonna start you guys off with a
quiz today
Oh pop quiz oh man okay kind of hope I
pass oh I've already give myself a full
F like guaranteed we're gonna start off
with an easy one I'm gonna give you guys
a few names you're gonna tell me yes or
no whether they actually are Pokemon or
something I just made up off the top of
my head no stress no pressure okay let's
do it
I like this school there's rdz Pikachu
yes you agree perfect perfect
yes how about pika mean no no I'll star
me no yeah oh yes suppose you're on how
about star you yes Nagi is also
perfectly done about Splenda yeah no
that's not my business sugar Splenda the
dietary sugar no right up Splenda that's
it that's a drink out of it for you back
on track thank you how about stack
attack
I found the craziest one yes but how
about Gus Lord yes she's got it yeah
definitely Pokemon surprise how about
Jackalope wait no no that's an animal
perfectly done no you said no so that's
a no-no right no how about swifty yes
getting swifty no I that's Rick and
Morty yeah mom no yes No right yes wow
that's crafty yes
crafty is one yes swirlix
yeah yeah yeah see you're cutting her
off she had it right swirlix yes yes yes
all about Skrillex no perfect Tippi he
could be there for all we know okay yeah
it's not a Pokemon but we do listen to
his music oh yeah no no with no
organization
how about heat more yes yes eat more
heat Oh eat more Oh is a chocolate bar
in the 80s it was if you're not Canadian
you probably wouldn't know it but it is
indeed a pokemon yes correct a
gargantuan no yeah you guys are on a
roll right now no good job Terry mom no
no it's correct that's the did you mom
yes it sounds like it that's a Digimon I
threw that whenever there's a real wild
card store Dave I would be so surprised
at that as a pokémon's not to put them
on but it isn't Digimon I threw that one
out on the right about Zigzagoon why you
asking me I'm supposed to be asking you
know that is Lucario yes good car dad
yes
yeah chikorita yes nicely done good job
take a read out can I also say that I
would boast about my Pokemon knowledge
and interviews and then I called
chikorita Chiquita
like the banana no it really wasn't
don't cater to anybody oh yeah that was
awful I was probably like batting about
30% there which will still get you in
the Hall of Fame yeah